my name is butterscotch I'm a singer
beatboxer first female beatbox world
champion and you may have seen me on
America's Got Talent and today we're
gonna break down 13 levels of complexity
and beatboxing beatboxing is the art of
vocal percussion so every sound you make
is only using your mouth it's one of the
most unique things that you can do
because everyone is different so we're
all gonna have some sort of different
style that we add so remember this is my
version of what makes beatboxing complex
level one bass drum so we're gonna start
with the simplest sound which is the
bass drum and this is the heartbeat it
sets the tempo and the tone for whatever
beat you're gonna do so the perfect way
to get this sound is to really
accentuate your lips and the air pushing
through and so what you're really doing
is forcing the air out of your mouth
it's gonna take time to build up that
muscle in your lips but once you get the
strength then it's gonna be a clean hard
so we have the bass drum but now we need
another percussive element to help drive
that beat level two snare so we're gonna
take the bass drum and add a snare to it
this is what actually makes the beak
it's not just a heartbeat
the easiest and quickest way to beatbox
is just to say boots and cats together
boots cats saying these two words
together are prepping your mouth for the
right form to the box suit what's the
right chance so when you say these two
words together
kind of creating a very simple rhythm
that people can play over or rap over or
jam over cats boots level three hi-hat
so we got the bass we've got the snare
and now we're adding the hi-hat and this
is completing the elements of the basic
sounds of a drum kick everything else
and beatboxing they're just
embellishments and if you want to see
the core elements here's a drum kit
you've got your base you've got your
snare and you've got your hi-hat
but the hi-hat you really want to make
these sounds tightened and this is what
makes the rhythm move it pushes it and
it sounds almost like a sprinkler - you
don't want it to be too loose because
then you're gonna you're gonna lose the
technical sound that you want that's
just not going to hit it you just gotta
make it clean high hats can be closed or
they can also be open so now that we
have our core sounds let's introduce a
basic beat so beats can be anything but
this is the simplest most basic hip-hop
beat so I'm taking the bass I'm taking
the snare and I'm taking the hi-hat and
I'm gonna put them in this order so I
can throw in another bass drum which
makes the rhythm in the pattern sound a
little bit more exciting it's one thing
to just make those sounds but over time
as you practice and your lips get
stronger
you're gonna sound like this so this is
super simple it's basically the mary had
a little lamb' of hip-hop beats if you
listen back to ladi Dadi Dougie fresh
the original human beatbox this is the
beat that's behind it so this whole time
the snare I've been using it can become
kind of monotonous if you're just always
using the same type of snare even just
within a song so what happens when I
change it up and make things a little
bit more complex
I can interchange the snare with a bunch
of other different sounds and that's
what makes it more dynamic I can do
sounds so combining the Shh you can mix
them all up and come up with all
different kinds of snares the post
sounds are more like hitting the snare
or drum machine whereas the sound is
like a rimshot you don't want to use all
the sounds all at once it'd be like
having a drummer just play
every single drum and it's not really
making a beat it's just sound so when
you first start beatboxing you're pretty
much gonna have to plan out your breaths
most of the snares that I'm using I'm
breathing outward so this is what it
looks like when all the sounds that I'm
using are breathing out I run on a
breath because there's no time to even
catch my breath whereas if I'm breathing
inward I can go faster I can breathe
while I'm actually beatboxing I can just
interlace my breathing with the beat
itself after a while then it just
becomes second nature and you can just
breathe within the beat so when you're a
drummer sometimes you make two sounds at
once I only have one mouth so this level
of complexity is taking two of the core
elements of the drum kit and putting
them together so here's my bass and
here's my hi-hat and I'm just going to
combine them so this is me doing it
normal and this is me adding the bass
and hi-hat together you can add multiple
sounds at the same time but we're gonna
save that for a couple levels later
everything we've been doing up to now
has been percussive but now level seven
adding a bass line I don't have the
vocal range to go super low but what I
can do is vibrate my lips and get this
certain frequency that creates this tone
in this pitch
so with this lip bass and basically just
vibrating my lips but this is getting a
tighter form and you're actually making
pitches and tones so I'm gonna take this
bass sound and add it to the beat
this is the limit of what I can do with
the bass sound since I don't have the
vocal cords that stretch that low but
with other beatboxers like inertia super
super low that create this like
subwoofer bass all levels up to now have
been using my mouth but now we're gonna
add another level of complexity by using
my throat level eight humming humming
and beatboxing is one of the most
difficult things because you're using
different parts of your mouth and your
throat and your lips all at the same
time so you want to get that humming
sound more kind of nasally and then
throw the beat on top of that
so when you're first starting out just
hum and then make the bass drum noise at
the same time hardest thing is adding
the snare on top of that because a lot
of people want to go but that doesn't
really sound that great if you go and
then that's a little bit cleaner so I'm
gonna take that bass sound and add
another note on top of it which gives it
a richer sound one of my favorite
beatboxers is the current world female
beatbox champion Kayla m'lady and she
adds these musical elements to make her
beatboxing stand out so far everything
we've done has been instrumental so
let's add some lyrics the easiest way to
begin is to start with B words because
you're already saying the with the bass
drum so you can say banana banana you
can say beat box beat box beat box you
can also use it with P because that's
the same shape that your mouth is
already making for those sounds pop tart
pop tart pop tart pop tart so with other
continents that's a little bit harder
crunchy taco crunchy taco there is a
split second like say if I'm saying
zebra I'm just saying a split hair after
I do the bass drum so it's zebra zebra
zebra but if I'm doing it so fast it
sounds like I'm doing it at the same
time zebra zebra zebra or if you have a
gust sound which sounds almost
impossible to do a in a good sound at
the same time but once you've been doing
it a long time pretty much any word is
possible gorilla gorilla
so the most exciting moment in beatbox
history for me is when rozelle beatbox
and sang at the same time he's saying if
if you wouldn't normally think of bass
drum and if would go at the same time if
yo mother mother at the same time that's
that's crazy too if yo mother only knew
[Music]
before that people had wrapped in
beatbox maybe did a little singing a
beatbox but it wasn't as cohesive and
clean and it blew people's minds that's
one of the reasons I'm beatboxing today
there's a form that's kind of taking off
as well that kid lucky started and
amazing beat boxers like Kayla m'lady
are doing it doing so now we're gonna
get more complex by adding different
sound effects this is where you find
your style and what really makes you
stand out so these are different sounds
that I've been developing over the years
I have two lip base tongue base growl
base slizzer roll trumpet scratching
yeah when I was younger I used to bark
like a dog I won't do that in class and
fire people you don't have to be good at
all these different sounds to be a good
beat boxer just find the sounds that you
love and that represent you and that's
your style I would say my trumpet is one
of my most unique and signature sounds
it brings out what makes my music me I'm
inspired by people like Miles Davis or
Dizzy Gillespie I love jazz and that's
what I grew up with I love classical
music so I'm trying to get better at
making a nice violin sound
[Music]
emulating real instruments are probably
the hardest because this is what people
are most familiar with when you're
trying to make the same sound you gotta
have it pretty spot-on before we move on
to level 11 here's the first 10 levels
all together be a beatbox for this next
level we're gonna go just back to the
beat but this time it's all about
new-school level 11 intricate beats so
I'm starting with a drum and bass beat
you can hear all the things that I'm
doing which sounds simple but as I go
faster it sounds a bit more complex this
level is more complex because your brain
has to catch up with what your mouth is
doing or your mouth has to catch up with
what your brain is trying to do but
everything starts with a very simple
beginning and you can just like work it
up and go as fast as you can you can
take it to the exponential level with
how fast you can go with how many sounds
you can do within a certain beat it's
incredibly technical so complexity isn't
just about going for speed for me it's
about being multi-dimensional for level
12 I'm doing a classic song swing low
Sweet Chariot and I'm singing beatboxing
and playing the guitar at the same time
so it's complex because my brain is
having to operate at a different level
trying to do the beat and play and
saying swing low Sweet Chariot
so I added trumpet at the beginning to
give it kind of a jazzy Flair that just
sets up the song and in this way so it
could be other instruments but I love
playing guitar I love taking classics
and just flipping them and making them
sound more new swing low Sweet Chariot
comin for to carry me home swing low
Sweet Chariot comin for Gamescom and its
last performance I'm gonna be live
looping which is overdubbing
all the instruments that you see I have
my keyboard my guitar my Loop Station
beatbox vocals different sound effects
and the classic trumpet sound so I sing
beatbox or play into the Loop Station
and it creates different layers that
overdub it's complex because I'm
combining so many different elements
different instruments there's no room
for error because every sound has to be
on the beat because it's looped
[Music]
swing low sweet coming for me round
sweet baby come upon carry me home swing
I love beatboxing because it's
completely unique you're able to do so
much just with your own body there's all
sorts of levels and intricacies of what
makes beatboxing multi-dimensional it's
portable it's fun and it's a pretty damn
special so I hope you enjoyed it and
thanks wired
[Music]
[Applause]